racism
what do you mean by systematic racism
like i'm just curious like what
institutions so okay so institutions
like the police
the police force people say
institutionally racist over here in i
think was 2007 there we had a guy called
burner bernard hogan how he was like the
head of the metropolitan police
and he was the head of the it's like
being the head of the police in america
right and he said uh you know well if
people say
you know our institution our institution
is institutionally racist uh there's
something we're gonna have to take on
the chin right that's what he said as as
the head
of the police so he knew
to some degree that his institution was
racist so institution so institutional
racism i believe actually exists
but
individual like race prejudice also
exists and i think sometimes people get
the two misconstrued and you can go as
far as saying that one is more real well
i've been historically racist like
redlining like redlining in america like
that was an institutionally racist thing
do you know what i mean like there is
institutional racism and i think people
get say oh that's racist it's like well
i i say the way to attack attack racism
would be institutionally what are the
institutions that enforce like schools
or i don't know education yes where
they're teaching i don't know a racist
i don't know doctrine in school or
something something like that i think
for those of us that don't know what
redlining is could you just explain it
okay so redlining was where um
if you wanted to buy a house right in
america um certain banks would not give
loans to black people right they would
only give them to white people so that
as the banking as an institution became
a racist institution because it was not
giving loans
to black businesses and two black people
for them to become wealthy yeah to go to
go into a business and when did that
like stop it stopped i don't think it
started
but technically it hasn't it has it has
that's that's one of the things where
even even i get looked at a bit wildly
yeah like institutional racism does
exist in certain areas but i think
certain things are just
they need to find a new because
redlining doesn't happen anymore it
doesn't exist it's on paper yeah on
paper that's what i'm saying so on paper
so
institutionally even that it has to we
have to find a new like covert
institution no because i have a class
in america so south africa was an
institutionally racist state yeah do you
know what i mean so institutional racism
exists but i think people need to
differentiate between what is
institutional racism and what is
individual race prejudice
i'm just curious with the redlining
thing like what what happened so they
they found that like they were lending
at different rates so basically to go
into more a little bit more information
so so to put it in the context of this
room what they would do is they would
say i'm gonna the good banks would say
i'm gonna give a loan but
only to people who live draw a line
right through us yeah over on that side
right knowing full well that they put
all the black people slavery in a
certain area and then cutting off the
line of where they would give loans to
live right if you lived in the hood you
couldn't get along because you lived in
the hood right but the thing is it was
like a chicken meat egg situation
because it's like you put them there
forcefully post whatever and then after
you put them there with no actual other
way to go
they can get loans to go live in the
middle class areas of the higher class
areas but i thought this was in like the
60s yeah so that was like a long time
after slavery so they could have moved
no i mean yeah but like but you have to
also no i mean like because there is
mass migrate i don't know like i there's
mass migrations in the us from the south
to the north yes and so you can't say no
because a lot of a lot of them did but
it became it was more of a thing where
it was um it was uh if i was to think
politically it was a attack the mindset
type of thing where if you know how some
people like once they're in the hood
that's just their mindset right and with
all some people eat sleep breathe the
hood it doesn't matter and they want to
live there for the rest of their they've
grown comfortable that's why they feel
safe now because because in my head like
why would you lend to people that live
in the hood
more yeah like i'm not i know
because usually like i'd imagine like in
poor communities you're not as good at
paying back money yeah but imagine but
imagine imagine imagine more of creating
a hood to then say why would i give
people
money you know you know tulsa you know
the um neighborhood coast of oklahoma
tulsa oklahoma yes yes black wall street
i'm sure pearl you've heard about it
obviously
no i don't know what that is okay so
black black wall street was a place in
america after slavery where black
millionaires existed there were loads of
black millionaires they were you know
business owners it was they had their
own like black economy where was that it
was in tulsa oklahoma oklahoma okay
okay so in tulsa oklahoma there was this
huge town like black people owned their
own planes they had their own businesses
they were like multi-millionaires they
did stock market all this kind of stuff
and then what happened was
the kkk and like other groups literally
burnt the town to the ground bombed it
from the the the the army bombed it from
the sky just totally got rid of that
town like killed everybody in the town
and i don't even see mississippi burning
that film called mitsusube burning
um
similar to that so
is this something to do with redlining
no i don't know okay
because the red lining came shortly
after that if you actually look at the
it did it came after that after they've
burned down this black um economy
redlining came in where was redlining at
like what cities worldwide oh it's all
over america
it was it was like a 50 state thing
where we have gone off topic but we have
no i i just genuinely i don't know a lot
about it
yeah essentially it was it was it was a
thing where state by state it was it was
statewide so it was a thing where at the
time it just seemed
like oh it was just the right thing to
do but when we when we look at it like
that's [ __ ] up and the the reason like
a lot of the hoods that exist today
exist today where they are is because
those are the relationships
all those poor people who had no money
and no funds to get out of there
for generations after generations but
that was like my dad was from the hood
and he just like left yeah so i'm like
what's stopping you from leaving the big
things
if you make like good choices and work
hard you can move out and it's not
no and that's what my dad was one of 13
kids he like grew up on the south side
of chicago in like a really bad area